[Applaudissements]
ça va lisser les cheveux
bah ça se voit vraiment surpris une
manière de faire différemment dresse je
doute on y va baa losique est ressorti
alors comme vous le savez j'adore
regarder les séries débutent aujourd'hui
recevait live je me suis fait une
spéciale mystères de l'amour a bien joué
il ya un malade l'ancien ma vie tu vois
là et en regardant les épisodes j'ai
compris comment les scénaristes avaient
fait pour tenir 142 saison c'est grâce à
elsa c'est parce que quand un peu moins
132 à peu près 40 240 points et c'est ça
bah c'est grâce à elsa c'est parce que
quand on commence une conversation avec
elsa ça peut durer sur quatre épisodes
avoir le dernier mot surtout super bien
se passer que les musiciens sont
excellents
oui mais ce que moi je vais être à la
hauteur dames en battant mais c'est pas
ton premier concert
rappelle toi sur ton premier album un
sofa du monde
on s'est également tancé
en avril à le concert avec ton père
ouais sauf que c'était ses musiciens pas
les miens m à nashville
ça chante avec les meilleurs musiciens
des états unis c'était un ch'ti que ça
continue et comme vous le savez dans
cette série une autre actrice mythique
qui s'appelle la libye est très premier
degré sur tout y compris sur ses
rapports intimes
du coup va falloir que nous explique le
concept de 2 me ce que je n'ai pas
encore mon mec il est formidable il même
c'est super c'est tout ce que je vois là
je comprends
c'est humiliant mais quoi
bah quoi après on a fait l'amour
3 le container jusqu'au bout de regarder
fait face à c'est un truc peuvent en
témoigner
le demi je sais pas ce que c'est on
cherche encore d'accord après ça j'ai
fait la connaissance d'un nouvel acteur
aussi fin d'un nouveau ouais bien sûr
hugo c'est un peu votre jean michel
maire avoue et hugo voilà dans cet
épisode a insisté vraiment auprès de
tout le monde pour que tout le monde
sache qu'il n'était pas plus haut il a
vraiment un point d'honneur là dessus en
revanche nous on n'a pas chômé à donner
un sens à ta donner aux trente ans j'ai
tout donné je veux dire je suis là et va
être réussie j'ai encore mal au tendon
bessat téléphone tu sais à chaque fois
tu fais tout pour elle tu donnes tu
donnes tu donnes tu te casses même les
rats géants tome alors 1 1 mais ça va
comme ça non non jamais mal orange une
souplesse et aussi on assiste parfois
dans votre série à des scènes d'une
extrême violence comme la séquence qui
suit bien sûr c'est une séquence
d'enlèvement alors malheureusement elle
est tellement pas crédible que même les
actrices en question ne savent pas que
c'est une scène dans les champs c'est un
peu macho bientôt très bientôt
très vite merci beaucoup
mais pourquoi mais je vous prie
[Applaudissements]
ces chauffeurs maintenant et j'ai
remarqué qu'il y avait une définition
différente du concept devait gagnent
quand je vois jordanie tu veux manger
je crois que j'en faisais des conneries
mais si c'est légal mais j'ai besoin de
force au cas où on n'aurait pas compris
un acteur a tenu à nous expliquer ce que
voulait dire en pleine action au cas où
et donc je suis en pleine action avec la
fin là d'un seul coup en train de sauter
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après ça je me suis fait l'épisode 1767
et je suis tombé sur l'acteur qui a le
plus de conviction c'est à dire que lui
et droit dans ses bottes on le fera pas
changer d'avis même pour de l'argent
quasi quoique ouais c'est ça mon temps
tu crois que ça m'éclate de montrer mon
cul à n'importe qui faut bien je gagne
ma vie donc l'om bien d'autres manières
de gagner sa vie mais tant qu'on est
beaucoup trop des jo où tu gagnes ou
1000 euros par mois huit mille balles
mais dis moi dis ils recrutent mais mes
coups mais pour finir dans l'épisode de
ce matin-là lee a découvert qu'elle
avait des dons de médium jeudi la libé
je parle pas de toi moi je parle de laly
l'autre actrice très connue a découvert
qu'elle avait des dons de médium et
justement elle a reçu un autre acteur en
consultation pour lui annoncer une bonne
et une mauvaise nouvelle
et heureusement pour lui il a pas la
même notion que nous de mauvaises
nouvelles ce qui l'a sauvé bon en tout
cas vous n'avez aucune inquiétude à
avoir mis fin à votre petite chienne va
vous revenir et très très vite
enfin quoi savoir comment ça me soulage
en revanche malheureusement pour votre
femme je suis si désolée ecoutez-moi dû
au manque retrouve ma chaîne
[Applaudissements]
un détail qu'il arrivait sur lui pour
franchir la seine tout mais merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]